hi and welcome to episode number 27 of
the weekly Google club back from podcast
i am francisco and i'm here with my
colleague mark brunell hey Mark hey
Francesca how are you doing pretty good
pretty good enjoying go to in Chicago
fancy how's that going it's surprisingly
hot but the conference is amazing very
good talks I just came out from talk by
sam newman on micro services and why he
basically had a slight saying that go is
the best language you can use so i'm
pretty happy that would make you happy
yes dear so today we're gonna be talking
about something slightly related to
micro services yeah we're gonna have an
interesting conversation with John Simek
John FEMEN della there we go that's fun
we're going to talk about unique annals
yep so basically what are unique kernels
why could you even care about them how
to use them what are the current
solutions technical solutions are
available are ready to run you any
Colonels and also how to run them on
Google cloud platform yeah so that's a
pretty cool and interesting thing and
then towards the end it's back to my
little pet project deployment manager we
have a really interesting question
around that as well yeah I like it
because it's basically how to do
deployment manager with a doing
deployment manager which is perfect I
really like it excellent well before we
get into those two things why don't we
have a quick chat about the cool thing
of the week and we've got a few things
given that you know google i/o was last
week yeah there were a lot of very
interesting announcements at Google i/o
but out of all the ones related to
google cloud by far my favorite one is
the new version of firebase yeah this is
pretty awesome we've gone from having a
few really interesting services with
firebase to having lots of really
interesting services with firebase it's
pretty amazing yeah and you still keep
on having that free tier up to 100
concurrent users which is actually more
than any of my famous however god I'm
very very very happy with that but on
top of that I
have a list in front of me but there was
analytics there was storage what else so
there's analytics there's storage so
cool integration with Google Cloud
storage it's just a really nice veneer
over the top we've got remote config for
doing like experiments being able to do
like like sort of value key value pairs
what other stuff we got in there there's
so many good things there's even like
little things like hand little tweaks to
how you can update data within the
real-time database all sorts of good
stuff nice so yeah we'll have a link on
the show notes to the commendation of
the new firebase so you can check it out
absolutely and we'll have links to all
the firebase sessions that are available
currently from IO there's a whole bunch
and most of them will be up currently at
though I know there's still a few coming
in as late stragglers actually not only
the ones related to firebase but all the
Google cloud platform talks that where
they're at Google i/o because I know
that you spoke about firebase but I
spoke about something else as [ __ ]
cluttering and yeah we'll also have a
link to that talk yeah yeah yeah mine's
a little delay do some minor technical
issues but hopefully should be up there
fairly soon well and also something that
I really enjoyed that was if anyone had
the chance to go to Google i/o they may
have seen that there was some really
cool demos in the cloud tent there was
the same two demos that we had at gcp
next so Cory it and TCP and model both
which are both pre really cool developed
by instrument yeah so if you're
interested in seeing some applications
of bigquery or possibly some
applications of Club vision API you can
dig into that code and see what it is
that they did to make the magic happen
yeah so we had those demos so just be
next Google i/o and now those that most
are open source all the code you can
find it on github so github.com /
instrument but we'll have the two links
to the repos on the show last year
absolutely so if you want to build a
motor booth in your house for like your
next party you can totally do that now
that is actually totally a good idea and
I've usually thought about it in
anything I'm serious I can see
in doing that for my for my next party
cool so I think it's time to go talk
with our friend John Fenella but you
know kernels yeah let's go talk about
unique kernels so I'm very happy to
welcome John Fay Manila to the google
app app from podcast hey Tom how are you
doing pretty good how about you guys
doing great pretty well so yeah I'm
actually very excited to have you here
because I saw you your talk at container
camp a couple weeks ago on uni kernels
and I thought it was a very very good
introduction to uni kernels explaining
why and how when all of those things so
I decided that it was it was a very good
idea to have you here but before we
start talking about uni kernels why
don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself sure so you already know my
name I'm John Pittman Ella most of what
I do on a day-to-day basis is to work
with a wonderful company called pivotal
and most of what I do at pivotal is to
work with a product called pivotal cloud
foundry where I serve as sort of a
technical advisor for companies that are
interested in taking a look at how they
modernize the way they do enterprise
software development so there was a lot
of really big banks and hospitals and
other major institutions large and small
that have an idea of how they build
software but maybe that idea hasn't
necessarily kept pace with the best
practices of how you deploy software in
modern cloud-based environment so we try
to help them with that with pivotal
cloud foundry and my job is to kind of
go from universe idealized version of
the way that software gets built and
help them apply that to their own their
own enterprises and make them better and
more efficient at developing software
and delivering it cool and how did you
get involved with uni kernels you does a
little bit about the story of how you
doing these kind of software cloud
software ends up doing a talk about
unique kernels sure again yeah so I
you'll often see me giving talks about
things that I have basically no
affiliation with but I find incredibly
interesting in some way and you know
kernels is one of the topics that's very
square
in that category so I'm I certainly
haven't haven't done any academic
research in the you know kernel space
which is a lot of where the genesis of
where we're seeing the interest in your
kernel has come from is very much
academic idea to start with that kind of
God gradually evolved into a industry
expiration buts now going on sort of
there haven't been many there are many
practical examples of your kernels until
I would say relatively recently in
computing history and and that that sort
of is what drew my attention to at first
was the academic side of the thing in
january 2014 was a publication made in a
magazine called communications of the
ACM and ca-siem is sort of a it's
halfway between a formal journal and
like a gossip magazine for computer
scientists and but probably i hope there
are no ca-siem board members on terms
that be very mad at that description but
it's basically a verra it's kind of a
way to get really interesting ideas out
in front of a large audience without
necessarily requiring the rigor of a
formal academic paper that you might
submit to a more a larger journal and i
loves the ACM for that reason because
it's a great bridge from academia to
kind of describe it they're working on
and for industry folks to kind of hear
about what's happening and up-and-coming
and so there was a paper published in
january 2014 called you know kernels the
rise of the virtual library operating
system written by and david j scott is
one of the authors and i'm probably
gonna mispronounce his name but if the
other authors and neo Madhava Madhava
petty and both of them were talking
about how this new way of consolidating
machine images and computing resources
and to sort of this discrete single
thing in a very specific tailored way
could yield enormous benefits and that
that was very interesting to me because
that's almost the same claim that was
made for the advantages for containers
and when containers were announced our
not announced when containers were being
developed over the last decade or a
couple of decades as a technology that
was one of the claims that the
proponents of containers often pointed
to was like there's this sort of
advantages to consolidating and
minimizing the surface area of what
you're actually delivering to a
production system and unicorn all seems
to be something of an extension of that
idea at least on the surface that's very
interesting to me because as someone who
works a lot with cloud computing and
working with these enterprises who
deliver software in the cloud I'm very
interested in what the correct or with
the interesting new ways of deploying
software in large-scale environments in
a reliable consistent and repeatable way
what that looks like in different
through different strategies and yoona
kernels definitely represents a new
point in the spectrum but I don't think
is really has really existed before so
there's a new sort of tool in our
toolbox that's evolving over time cool
so before we start talking about the the
advantages or disadvantages of uni
kernels well then you tell us a little
bit about what is it you need colonel
specifically from the point of view of
someone that like me knows darker but
that's pretty much it sure so if you
know about docker you probably know that
the way that docker is able to deliver
some of the isolation advantages that it
has is because there are specific hooks
inside of your kernel that allow a
machine that's running docker to
guarantee those isolation properties so
your kernel is in some sense aware of
this and it's providing those benefits
for you in older more traditional style
isolation through virtual machines the
way that you get isolation is by running
an entire new OS stack on top of your
existing OS and existing services and
libraries so you're basically repeating
all the work of building an OS
and with something like docker or can
another containerisation technology
you're removing the need to have kind of
a big heavy colonel in there and you
kind of just have lightweight hooks into
your real running kernel and then you
get performance advantages by not having
to make by not having to virtualize
those calls across as many layers as a
virtual machine has to and you know
kernels go one step farther and you know
kernels are based on the observation
that if you have if you have a kernel
and you have an OS in the form of
additional services and libraries on top
of the kernel that are made available to
applications if you have that you it's
pretty you pretty quickly reach the
conclusion that well not every
application running on top of that stack
needs everything that's in the whole OS
and in the whole kernel right so you're
you know your web browser probably
doesn't need probably needs a lot of the
colonel but probably doesn't necessarily
need things like you know access to
nature of serial port or whatever and so
anything that's true for many different
kinds of applications that don't need
access to the entire colonel so you know
kernels are a way of saying well what if
we didn't need to have the whole kernel
around the whole OS around for an
application what if we could just take
the pieces that are relevant to an
application and what if we could run it
that way what if we could sort of only
expose or make available to the
application the parts that it really
depends on and if we can do that then
maybe we can ship that entire dependency
stack as a single consolidated machine
image and then just like we can run
docker containers containing images we
should be able to run a sort of a
container around this consolidated
machine image but because that image is
is effectively an entire operating
system in a bottle you could run that on
their metal or on a hypervisor or
whatever so there's a lot nbme also
because it's so much smaller there's you
know we expect to see certain benefits
around like maybe it's quicker to start
things up then it would be to start a
container or a virtual machine and so on
so once you start thinking about how can
we shrink the set of stuff you actually
need to only the dependencies required
by a process or an application it starts
really motivating some interesting
thought patterns around how we're going
to design those applications what kinds
of applications are really well-suited
for this and which ones aren't and so on
so it really opens up a new space to
think about how to deliver and deploy
and maybe even design or applications to
take advantage of that cool so that
sounds really interesting but from a
practical point of view how do I like
run a unit Colonel how do I build a you
know Colonel what is there tooling
available like I'm obviously familiar
with sort of containers I can sort of
put those in the cloud but if I want to
do I need to run each on an individual
machine how does that work sure so there
are again this is still very much an
evolving space but there are many
different right now we're sort of in
this meritocracy phase of where
everyone's trying to do a bunch of
different projects we're trying to
figure out like what are the best
approaches and that's still very much an
evolving idea so there have been a
couple of attempts to consolidate these
ideas into one location where people can
play around with them but there hasn't
been much consolidation that I've seen
in the way of projects so people are
still kind of independently exploring
many different ideas and to get a taste
of the many different ways that we get
started with your kernels I would
recommend that folks check out a website
called Yura kernel.org and this is the
work of a couple of people including
Amir chaudhury who is formally at your
kernel systems and is now with docker
and he's done a great job of kind of
collecting these different projects into
a single place and giving you a really
broad exposure to the many different
kinds of ways that you could actually
build a unit colonel i will say that
broadly speaking there are two basic
strategies you either start with an
applique
nation that is that exists or yours or
you're willing to start from scratch to
build some service or whatever if you're
starting from an application that
already exists you probably have a POSIX
compatible application and if that's
true then you can use something called
rump run which is a way of taking your
it basically a rump kernel is a special
flavor of you know Colonel where
basically you can build the software
stack you need for your application
without having to build all the
individual pieces yourself so for
example if you if you don't want to all
the overhead of an OS you still may need
drivers to actually run that OS so for
example your web application probably
needs access to ccp IP protocol stacks
and things like that so you still need
these pieces to run your application and
a rump colonel lets you assemble those
pieces in a way that's POSIX compliant
but your application will still probably
work and so you can run that's one way
of minimizing what comes along for the
ride with your application so you wind
up with a very compact image then you
can run on top of raw hardware or cloud
hypervisor so kb hammers and you take
this image menu it run it on top of zen
let's say so that's one strategy the
second strategy is you are willing to
sort of start from scratch so maybe
you're just experimenting for example
and there are language i'm going to call
broadly language-specific kernels
unicorn holes so there are operating
system stacks that require your
application to be written in a very
specific language so for example miraj
OS is the is what i would say is the
canonical you know colonel OS 40 camel
at this point so mirage OS has a bunch
of libraries you have your application
you say hey I depend on you know I need
a networking stack or whatever and the
Mirage OS compiler determines that you
know what the set of libraries you need
is and then compiles that into a machine
image
that you can then run just like you did
with the rum colonel you can run that
machine image on top of Zen now the
extent to which each project supports
this or the levels of documentation and
how easy it is to get started very
really wildly I I consider myself a
relative o camel novice but i really
liked mirage OS i liked getting started
with o camel and i built a really small
web service that talks to a few
different it's just like a quote service
so you can talk to yahoo and get like
the you know the stock price of a
particular quote and things like that so
but it's really easy to build and it was
very straightforward so I but I've been
liking Mirage OS the most that's
obviously with the others aren't also
great but you know I only had so much
time and I didn't want to learn like 37
languages to try 37 different flavors of
your kernel OS but that's that's the
basic idea is you kind of have some
mechanism that turns your application
into a compact machine image and then
you run that compact machine image on a
hypervisor of some kind that sits on top
of your bare metal and and then you're
running your you're running your unit
Colonel at that point so then it can
receive a quest on the internet or you
know right to a database or whatever
else is supposed to be doing cool so if
I understand that correctly that's the
mean that if I'm running for instance a
web server in let's say go cuz I like go
I could eventually rather than building
a binary than runs on linux I could run
I could build a linux like a unique
kernel that contains my app and all the
libraries that it needs like dnas and
all that stuff that a good need for for
web servers but it could not include
things like I don't know like us bc
controller or floppy disk taller stuff
like that it is that correct yes right
so when you let now normally the
container that like like if you're
running on alpine Linux it it probably
it saved a lot of space by omitting a
lot of
kinds of firmware are things that aren't
going to need for a web application so
you're it is probably saving some space
there by using just a small base image
for for something like a docker
container but for your go web
application example what you'd save over
the docker container are all the parts
that you would literally be removing
everything when the colonel but your
application doesn't actually depend on
like when you use a when you use a base
image from someone else's docker layer
you're basically saying I'm going to use
that because i know it's minimal but
there's no guarantee from a compiler or
from something else that there isn't
stuff in there but you don't need right
like you're still there's no there's no
tool that's taking your application
analyzing it in some way and then saying
ok here's what you actually depend on
here's the system calls you're making or
whatever and then arriving and then
compiling that you know Colonel so you
have to sort of a I think the goal is
that effectively you have a stronger
guarantee about that thing that's the
output of the compilation process being
minimal in some for some definition of
minimal that is it's a smaller to run
it's quicker to start up and so on so
that that's what I would say is that I
think you're essentially right but I
think there's the key difference in that
a computer is a computer program is
making it a decision about what's going
into your image as opposed to a human
being saying I want this and I want that
and I want this other thing that's sort
of that cool i would say that
fundamental distinction so I could I
could say that it's basically the
difference between having just a binary
with all the possible symbols of all the
libraries that you are actually
importing to actually stripping the
binary down to the objects that you're
actually using that your program is
actually using right I would say is that
it I would take it one step farther
which is that your go binary when you
deploy that you run that as a process on
an operating system the equivalent thing
on a unicorn ille is that you run that
and it is the operating system the only
thing it knows how to do is run your web
server it can you know it can't
out of my sequel it can't connect to
gratis or whatever the only thing I
knows how to do is run your process is a
single consolidated machine image so
it's like the colonel it would be as
though the Linux kernel was explicitly
written to run your go web server and
your girl web application and nothing
else so you're just starting that's that
thing and then you're making a million
copies of it or whatever so it could be
like the Linux the Linux that I could
start it could be a distribution that
only contains my binary and my binary
could be run as like process ID 0 or
whatever but like right it could be the
main process interesting exactly it's
kind of like if you're familiar with the
privilege levels in traditional kernels
you may have heard of things like bring
0 ring one ring to ring 3 so user land
code in usually execute this
unprivileged it lives in the top ring
and then there are basically context
switches that happen into privileged
mode I mean that's how your kernel is
able to do things with device drivers
and right to protected areas of memory
and so on with a unicorn ille operating
system your application / machine image
is executing everything in privileged
mode everything happens at ring 0
there's no context which is there's no
there's no handing back and forth to
user land code because there is no use
your lab coat everything is inside the
kernel itself cool so does that mean
that if I'm building myself a unit
colonel app I need to understand how
like the Linux kernel works at a low
level so that I can tell it what drivers
to put in and pull out or how is that
process managed yeah I mean that's part
of blue the usability efforts I think
we're coming in so first of all it's not
necessarily the case that you need
quote-unquote a like Linux kernel
understanding because there's so much
modification happening to these unit
Colonel OS is that some of them like if
you look to what the kernel code looks
like it would be unrecognizable compared
to the delay linux kernel code like
there's probably some basic ideas that
are going to be in every modern
operating system like you know maybe the
idea of like memory allocation and
virtual memory or things like that so
those ideas will
we have familiar implementations but in
terms of like looking at the code and
like and eating to understand what some
constant means or something like that
and now you don't really have to do any
of that to get started so like mirage OS
for instance you i will say their
documentation is very good but basically
you effectively just write a 0 camel
application and from your applications
perspective nothing really looks
different like you can't tell that it's
running on a unicorn ille environment
you know the Miraj OS compiler is taking
care of all the details of how that
application is actually doing things
because it's it's it's sort of using its
own stack in its own kernel its own OS
its own kernel OS and services on top of
that OS to make it up to make your
application work in this environment and
that's great because it means that all
the stuff that your application doesn't
rely on is not part of the colonel to
begin with so you again save the extra
heavyweight steps or extra heavyweight
bits of the kernel that you are not
using cool so we almost running out of
time but there's a topic that I could
not be happy living out which is what
about people that say that unique
kernels are not fit for production sure
I mean I think that that's maybe a
little premature given that it's still a
relatively new area of not only
development but I think I think also
thought about like philosophy of how
we're going to use this and I think it's
I think we don't want to be too quick to
set aside a tool just because there may
be some valid objections to it to begin
with you know I think that probably
containers were not ready for a
production in 2013 when or if i should
say docker wasn't really ready for
production in 2013 and Solomon hikes and
all the doc were people like
vociferously said this multiple times
throughout 2013 and it's not ready for
production but you know if you're a
brave and you want to experiment with it
you certainly can and I think that's
kind of the phase were in now with your
new kernels where
this is really just starting to catch
the attention of people and there are
many implementations they're all trying
to demonstrate that their aversion is
it's a good one and we're still waiting
for the dust to settle a lot before we
start getting into these more specific
details of like how does debugging work
in a unicorn environment how does how
does tracing work what's the right way
to do that how do you how do you deploy
these things are the kinds of
applications that are suitable for you
know kernels may be different than what
we're imagining or what we think might
be suitable so there's a whole range of
I think questions we can ask about your
new kernels that don't have answers
right now orbit or that we're working on
trying to figure out the community is
working on trying to figure out the
answers for so it's definitely still
early days and I certainly wouldn't be
like you know running my fortune 100
bank enterprise stuff on it but but I
think it's absolutely worth taking a
look at keeping an eye on because
chances are good that in 2018 when you
guys have me on for that to your
anniversary of this podcast you you can
ask me where wherever you know Colonel
spin in the last two years and i bet my
answer will be something like this it
probably took the same path that
containers did where there was gradual
adoption we realized that there is a
specialized use case for for this
technology and then we exploited that
specialized use case to really get the
benefits of the technology just like
containers aren't suitable for all
possible applications you know kernels
won't be suitable for all possible
applications there will be some specific
set of things that's really well suited
for you know kernels and some things
that aren't and that's okay very
interesting and since you mentioned you
actually mentioned amira chaudhary from
docker and you also mentioned docker so
I got to meet him during craft humph
we'll have a link to the slides of his
talk we're really interesting but I'd be
curious to know your opinion on why do
you think Amir is now working for dr.
meaning why did darker by that unicorns
company
yeah so first of all just say that I've
never actually met him here in person
but we've chatted a bunch over google
hangout so thanks google but he is just
you know clearly doing amazing things
and it's a brilliant person and I you
know I think that even if the company
had zero value it would probably be
worth it so hire a mirror and his team
because like you can just there's a
certain set of people wait if you talk
to them you just realize it whatever
they're working on is probably going to
be amazing and so I don't want to set
them you're up for too much pressure but
I'm sure that whatever he's working out
it's going to be great and I look
forward to seeing it so I think if
docker hired them it's probably because
they saw what a mirror and his team were
capable of and what they were building
and they wanted a piece of that and I
think it's probably fair to say that if
docker bought a company called yoona
colonel systems and the word you know
colonel is right in the name then
they're certainly exploring and we're
actively using your new kernels in in a
way that's probably ahead of the rest of
the industry at this point so I expect
that if we as we start seeing industry
best practices come out of the operation
of things like you know kernels I I
expect to hear a lot about docker and
what they're doing with it and kind of
look to them it's a role model for how
we use your new kernels well I guess I
guess we have to wait till the second
anniversary of the spot w again and see
let's see how much of that was your back
in time so we are running out of time a
little bit jump but is there anything
that you would like to mention that you
haven't had a chance to mention yet or
topic you want to cover real quick well
I would say that if folks are what was
it one of the things that I'm very
interested in is how businesses use
platforms in in their in their
deployment pipeline like where do they
see platforms coming into play and we've
gradually been we've been very excited
about containers then people realize
okay well the orchestration of
containers is a problem so we have
things like Cooper Nettie's and other
technologies to help us like manage
those containers
I still feel like there's something that
is that we should be thinking about as
an industry in the workflow with respect
to if you had to develop or a container
or a unicorn or a virtual machine or
something that's not their application
then they're still responsible for a lot
of the a lot of the stack right I'd have
to do a lot more things before it's
actually running and that's something
that I I want to see us as an industry
move towards better tooling around how
we manage containers and how we turn
applications into it's running somewhere
and I can like you know hit it with an
HTTP request and that I think is an area
that's that we need to pay more
attention to and then we are sort of
slowly evolving platforms are playing a
role on that but I know that we're going
to see awesome things come out of Coober
Nettie's and other technologies so I'm
trying to I'm encouraging the listeners
of this podcast to think about when you
deploy an application is your is your
next step like put this in a container
or do you want this to be hey do
something that puts us in a container
for me so I don't have to worry about
the details like that I think is a
really interesting proposition when I
can get back to writing code instead of
you know like operationally managing 37
containers and clustering technologies
and whatnot very good very very
interesting I thought I agree with that
actually well thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us today cool
yeah thanks for having me and talk to
you in two years yeah i'll see you on
may12 2018 excellent will book it in now
yeah all right thanks guys thanks so
much John for joining us on the podcast
today that was a really interesting and
enlightening talk about you know Colonel
something to keep an eye on for sure
yeah and we'll definitely have the link
to the turkey stock container camp I
think it was it was a very good talk so
if you're curious about more details on
any Colonels is probably a good resource
to go check out absolutely but um let's
talk about the question of the week
franceschi you had a really interesting
question there yeah so the question is
regarding
your pet your pet peeve your favorite
project deployment project yeah diploma
manager and it's basically about okay so
deployment manager basically what it
allows you to do is given a file that
contains some description you will
create all the resources on your Google
cloud platform project and that is that
is cool but is there any way you can
create that file from what you already
have mean that you via either the CLI or
the other web interface you created a
bunch of not an out-group instances and
cloud storage buckets and whatever and
you want to basically create the
corresponding deployment manager so then
you can replicate that same frustra
somewhere else so as about 15 days ago
there is a beginning of doing exactly
that I would say it's definitely not
like a hundred percent there but it's an
open source project that sits within the
Google cloud platform deployment manager
samples repository where there's a gen
config Python script where you're able
to point it I think primarily right now
at GCE instances but hopefully that will
sort of grow from there and as we get
issues and pull requests and be able to
get back a basic sort of ginger template
that's able to be used with deployment
manager I think you'll have to tweak it
a little bit but it definitely does a
lot of that bulk work for you so that if
you want to get started with deployment
manager but you've already got some
infrastructure and you want to basically
be able to either replicate that
somewhere else or maybe modify it using
deployment manager this is a really
great place to start yeah that sounds
really like a very good place to get
your file started and then from there
you're gonna see all the things that
you're missing and there's two things
that you can do one is add them to the
file the other one is send a full
request yeah absolutely yeah so I mean
this is on github right now links are in
the show notes so if you start using it
you find issues definitely submit it
back we'd love to have input from the
community and I'm curious about one
thing in what language is written ah
Python Ivan hazel Simon oh well oh well
I might still I must contribute to it
cool so before we finish why don't you
tell us mark were what are you gonna be
doing in the next in the next couple
weeks
so next week third of June here in the
SF Google office there is the gaming
event we're having here change the game
I'll be here for that i'll be doing
possibly 11 and a half presentations so
I'm co-presenting possibly a couple
times depending on how things pan out
but that should be a really fun event we
can have Googlers there to talk to
people if you're interested in game dev
you want to hear from both customers and
Googlers and talk to like Google and
people about products absolutely come
down I'm going to be around all over the
place after that i'll be visiting GDG
Twin Cities i'll be at open source north
after that i'll be at a conference staff
objective and then I think I'll be in
New York later in the month for another
gaming event I haven't got all the
details for that either Wow bouncing
around a bit how about yourself where
you off to not much just biking from San
Francisco to Los Angeles like one does
that that's pretty much it after that
i'm relaxing until july where it will
speak at gopher come very nice very very
nice what are you speaking on a graphic
on i'm talking about nothing literally
i'm gonna be presenting the name of the
notes are keys understanding mail so
it's basically this seinfeld episode of
gopher con exactly I yeah and it's gonna
be the opening keynote so I don't know
how that's gonna go I think it's gonna
be fun I will have fun that's for sure
it'll be fantastic I expect big things
so before we finish this episode there's
this one more topic that you're actually
not ready to discuss but I would like to
to bring it up which is which is that
amazing match that we had playing quiet
at Google i/o oh yes oh yeah I just
wanted to make everybody know that I
basically I this fried you you won by
like thin margin like a thin margin yeah
a little bit anyway luck yeah luck
obviously that's what that's what ya
using standing in front of that for like
the whole day you knew all the questions
that might be true that might be true a
little bit of my budget there yes that's
how we settle battles here at Google we
play query it yep
using the big the power of big data to
settle bottles exactly so thank you so
much for joining me yet again this week
France desk always appreciate you taking
the time thank you Mark and thanks very
much to all our listeners out there too
we really appreciate you coming and
listening to a speak we love having you
listen and provide comments and do all
that sort of good stuff too yeah and
talk to you all next week see you next
week
you